So that about wraps us up. Thanks very much for watching everyone, I think that takes us to the end.
Obviously for all of this stuff you can find out more detail on the Unreal documentation.
On Unreal YouTube there's live streams about new features, talks from various developers actually working on the engine themselves.
Same thing for the Twitch streams.
Unreal Developer Network is available to anyone who's an Unreal Engine licensee.
For anyone who isn't a licensee we also have the AnswerHub.
Epic recently announced a new category of answer that is pulling some of the highest traffic answered questions from the UDN.
So from real licensee dev scenarios and bringing them over into the AnswerHub.
So the rest of the community can see those, so that's very exciting.
And last off we have the Unreal Engine Community Wiki.
Which is basically where the community could be uploading tutorials and documentation.
The only thing to mention there is that some of those solutions may not always be the most efficient.
And may be slightly out of date.
They don't have the same kind of burden and requirement of keeping these things up to date as Epic's own materials do.
But all of these are fantastic resources and peruse them at your own leisure.
Thanks very much for watching everyone and I hope you have a great rest of your day.